Elsie was just three when she was
diagnosed with a rare bone marrow
condition it meant her little body had
no immunity to fight infection the last
infection she had she she was given
pretty much everything she was throwing
everything at her and we were we were
sort of sat down and told they were
doing everything and it was kind of make
or break really and I remember saying to
our consultant I can't see her go
through another infection like this
because I don't think she'll she'll make
it and she kind of she just agreed
Elsie needed a stem cell transplant that
meant taking healthy stem cells from the
blood or in LC's case bone marrow of
someone who was a genetic match
her younger sister Maya wasn't one
but then the family were told there was
a match on a UK stem cell donor register
a stranger who has saved Elsie's life
they've no idea who we are what it means
to us even how old else he is you know
she she's could be anyone all they've
done is they've they've donated their
cells and they've they've saved her life
um it's just it's an incredibly selfless
act from a stranger and it's it's huge
it's amazing but charity is a warning of
a steep decline in the number of people
signing up to be possible stem cell
donors there are currently nearly 970
000 potential stem cell donors on the
dkms UK register but since 2019 new
sign-ups have more than halved look at
last year 2022 when just under 76 000
people registered their DNA compare that
to 2020 when even though we were in the
middle of the covert pandemic more than
150 000 people did the more people there
are on the Registries the more likely it
is that we will find a donor for a
patient but not just a donor a perfectly
matched donor getting on the register is
very straightforward you can sign up on
the dkms or Anthony Nolan website and
you simply need to fill in your details
and they send you a swab that you just
rub on your cheek to get some DNA and
send that back we first met Peter
mccleave nearly three years ago he has
blood cancer and told us then that
without a stem cell transplant he had
seven years to live
but Peter's Southeast Asian Heritage
means it's harder for him to find a
genetic match today he's still waiting
if you are quite European then you've
got north of 70 chance of finding your
stem cell don't match but for any other
minority ethnic group your chances of
finding your life-saving match drop to
at best 37 I'm still looking for that
stem cell during a match I know they're
out there and often when you explain to
someone that you could potentially save
someone's life through nothing more than
a cheek swab it's not invasive it's not
painful
people engage because you understand
that actually there is a moment of
altruism right there where you could
potentially save someone's life if
plant
all are looking for a donor who could be
a stranger
who could save their life
Catherine ovato see Sky News